Well thank you. I know you, you
had uh an alternative today, you
could have gone and watched the keynote from uh
from, from Werner, so we really appreciate you
dedicated folks coming and spending
what I think is the last session of the day um
with us, um, so hopefully it's worth it. In
fact, we know it'll be worth it.
You're gonna walk away with some hopefully interesting
uh ideas and, and, uh.
Things you can take back and apply to your own
organizations. So this is SEC 341,
automating IEM policy validation
and analysis using GitHub
actions.
Uh, if it's not the session you
thought it was going to be, I'm afraid the doors
are already closed, so you can't leave
now.
Um, but please stick around, I think you'll, you'll get something out
of it. Uh, my name's Mitch.
I'm a solutions architect for AWS
based in Sydney,
Australia, and I get to work with our financial
services customers, so identity
is a pretty common topic that I spend a bunch
of time talking about with them.
And it's my pleasure to be joined here by
Nitin today. Yeah, hi everyone, uh, my
name is Nitin Kulkarni.
I'm also a solutions architect in the
identity Solutions Team,
uh, based out of Arlington, Virginia.
So you've hopefully got an idea of
what we're going to talk about from the title of the session
and the synopsis if you, if you read it,
but um.
And it's a code talk, so it's supposed
to be uh a lot more practical and hands
on than uh than
it is slides, but
we're gonna level set with a few slides, we're gonna try
and keep them to an absolute minimum, but I just
think it's important that you get the idea of,
of where we're going with this, where we've
come from, and the problem that we're trying to help
solve with what we're gonna present to you today.
And um and then we'll get straight into
the practical parts uh and uh
and um
we'll, we'll.
As we're going through this, um, because there's not too
many people here, if, if there are questions,
you can put your hands up and we'll we'll have a go at asking them
for answering them for you.
Um, equally if, if you want to wait till
the end, you can do that as well. We're, we're pretty flexible,
I think, uh, with, with timing at the minute.
So what we're gonna cover, uh, traditional IEM
models, and I'll explain what I mean by that in a second.
We're gonna give everyone a quick overview of GitHub actions,
but last time we ran this, which was yesterday,
most people seemed to already know what that was.
Show of hands, who's using or used GitHub
actions?
Yeah, OK, it's pretty similar to what we got
yesterday, which is good.
Then a quick, a quick overview of IEM Access
Analyzer, which is gonna form the basis
of the practical part of what we're doing today,
uh, and really help solve the problem that we're trying to solve.
Uh, a quick introduction to custom policy checks,
which is a feature of Access Analyzer,
and then we're gonna get into the building part of it.
So, what do I mean by the traditional models
of IAM,
uh, in the context of today's session, we mean
the way in which IAM policies
in particular and, and, and roles
and, and users in some cases, but essentially
the things you create in the IAM part of the
AWS console,
how they're managed within your organizations.
Um, traditionally,
one of the patterns that we saw used quite a
lot was the centralized model, and
that's where there was a clear delineation between the
security team and the software engineers within the
organization. The security engineers would
be responsible for creating
the policies.
Um, they often created them
in standard patterns, maybe t-shirt
sizes with
certain permissions based on persona, developer,
um, you know,
knowledge worker, those kinds of things.
Then the builders who are creating
the software, the applications within the
organization would, um, would have to use what
they're given. Um, they would be given a policy.
It might be slightly overly
permissive for what they needed, but it, it met their
requirements, um,
so, you know, that, that was the pattern that we
saw used quite a lot in many organizations
and, and maybe is still used in some
places today.
The challenge with this is that
several challenges. One is that the
security engineering team.
Tend not to know much about the
applications that are being developed, so
the policies can either be way
too broad or way too narrow in
terms of scope, making it hard for the software
engineers to get the exact outcome they're looking
for. The other challenge is that there are
a finite number of security engineers. Any
security people in the room here today?
Yeah, there you go. So those are the unicorns, you guys will
be asking for pay rises from your managers soon.
Um, yep, I mean there were some statistics I
read that the, the cybersecurity
industry is short some, I don't know, there's some ridiculous
amount, millions of security engineers. Um,
so if you want to change roles and practices,
security is the way to go.
Um, so there are finite numbers of those,
and not enough, and when the security engineering
team is getting feedback from the software builders
that they need to keep tweaking these policies,
they become a bottleneck.
So that's the centralized model. It doesn't
necessarily work too well because you often end up
with with these challenges, these bottlenecks,
and policies that are either
too permissive or not permissive enough.
Then we've got the gated model. Um, this is
slightly more in the direction that we think
we should be going. This is where our security
teams are.
Um, Essentially they're to act as risk
advisors, um, risk assessors
if you like, of policies that are being created,
so the builders themselves who
understand the applications will create
the policies as part of their builder workflow.
Um, they, they may not fully
understand the intricacies of the very expressive
I IAM policy language, but they'll
have a good crack, they'll create a policy, they'll submit
it along with their
application code or whatever mechanism they use
to submit these things, and then the
security engineering team will step in and they'll
review that,
um, better because the policies
are more scoped to what the application actually
needs because the app engineers understand it.
Slightly more challenging from a security engineer perspective
because depending on how many times these developers are committing
these requests for new policies,
you could be backwards and forwards, backwards and forwards. The
other challenge is again,
because you're a security engineer and you don't have the
context of the application,
a lot of the time you might be questioning
why they've done certain things, and there can be tangos
going on between the security teams and. The builder
teams as they negotiate, why are you
doing this? Have you considered this, this is not best
practice backwards and forwards, backwards and forwards.
Um, if the policies
themselves become, um, uh,
uh, when they're analyzed by the, the builder team, sorry,
by the security teams have issues, um,
you know, the, the developers, uh, will get notified
by the security engineers and, and there'll be
rework that has to be done.
So better
but not perfect.
And I'm not saying the next model is perfect either,
but this is an improvement on the, the
delegate, the, the, the gated model.
So this is where what we're doing with our security
engineers is we're really going to allow them
to use their judgment and skills to
focus on things that we can't solve automatically.
So instead of manually reviewing all of these policies
or creating a bunch of policies and making them available
to, to, to the engineers, the builders,
and what they do is they build automation,
um, so that when the builder
submits their IM policy.
It will automatically get analyzed
or assessed against a set of
organizational standards, guard rails, best
practices, whatever you want to call them, or whatever you want
them to be.
If there happens to be a
blocking change or or a finding that's
identified in that process,
then the security engineer can be engaged
either automatically or through, you know, through
a failed build in a pipeline,
um, they can have a look, they can
have a conversation with the builder or
the. Automation
can send notifications directly back to
the engineer to say
it's failed,
uh, here's, you know, here's why it's failed, and
then the builder has to go and figure out how to, how
to fix and resolve that problem.
So better, definitely better, um, definitely
removing a lot of dependency on the security
engineer there, allowing the developer to move much
faster, and if their policy is good and well
within the constraints or the, the, the scope, then
it gets, it gets pushed straight out into whatever
environment, um,
it needs to.
And we're gonna, we're gonna kind of talk through.
That process today, but an evolution of
that process because one of the
examples I gave there was that the builder
gets the feedback automatically either from
uh as part of the pipeline. I
check it in, I've got a blocking finding,
I get some feedback, I've got to go and figure out how
to fix that.
So we, we, we've enhanced the delegated model
a little bit with what we're gonna show you today
to provide some of that prescriptive guidance, and you'll
see more as we go through it.
Right, GitHub actions, what is GitHub
actions? Uh, for those of you that haven't used
it, which didn't seem to be too many people in the
room at all,
it's essentially GitHub's native, uh,
CICD, um, automation
platform and orchestration platform.
It allows you to run,
uh, actions, funnily enough.
Or arbitrary code in some cases
depend based on
events that occur within a repository. This
can be a committed change. It can be a pull
request. It can be an issue getting logged,
and these workflows, so the actions,
the
arbitrary code code if you decide to run that,
will run on
ephemeral runners they're called. They
can be managed by GitHub
or they can be self-hosted and managed within your own
environments.
These workflows get defined in YAML files,
um, because everyone loves the YAML files,
and we're gonna show you one of these workflows, in
case you haven't seen one recently, um, in a,
in a little bit more detail as we go through the session
today. Access
Analyzer, what is Access Analyzer,
show of hands, who's using Access Analyzer?
Few people, OK, cool.
So this is our um.
Our automated reasoning
powered tool
for analyzing your policies,
um, be they identity policies or
resource policies,
to determine if certain
properties are true or or not
true. Um, in the case of
the very first version of Access
Analyzer that we deployed, um, we
had an analyzer called External Access Analyzer,
which is still available today. You should turn
it on in your AWS accounts if you don't have it on
because it's free.
And it does a really good job of telling
you whether or not things in your AWS account
are accessible publicly, um,
and it uses
automated reasoning, so essentially mathematics,
um, to give you mathematical mathematically
verified answers to the question.
Is this thing true? Is this assumed property
true? Is it public? Yes, no. Can
this identity policy do this or
that, yes or no?
Um, and we, we call this at AWS provable
security. If you Google search provable security,
you'll be able to dive a bit deeper into that.
That's pretty much all I'm going to say about,
uh, automated reasoning, uh,
and formal logic and, and provable
security because I don't have a PhD in that and I
do a really bad,
uh. Job of trying to explain the science
behind it, but if you Google it, you'll find some really good
examples of, of that and some really good papers that
some of our colleagues have published in this space.
One of the other features of Access
Analyzer beyond external analyzer
and the other ones I mentioned as well
is um.
Custom policy checks. So these are 4,
stateless APIs
that will use automated reasoning, um,
to, well,
will mostly for, for most of those actions,
not, not validate validate policy.
They'll use essentially use automated reasoning or
a variation of that to, um,
help you answer questions about policies
that you want to check.
So here's a policy, um, does it conform
to AWS 100 best practices,
uh, and is it syntactically correct?
That's validate policy.
Um, here's a policy. Does it allow
a subset of my maximum allowable
organizational permissions? That's custom policy
checks, uh, sorry, check access, not granted.
Here's a policy,
um, I'm sorry, check no new
access. Here's a policy, does it allow
access to this resource or does it allow access
to this action? And that's what, um,
check, access not granted is.
And can anyone guess what check no public
access does?
We'll leave it there.
Um
So what are we gonna build?
Uh, what's knitting gonna build today? We're
gonna build this, this is a bit like our delegated
workflow you saw on the slide a bit earlier on,
with
the added benefit of a
little bit of intelligence when we get
a failure.
So when we identify a blocking finding, and
we're gonna use custom policy checks as part
of this pipeline,
so as a policy gets submitted and starts
working its way through this flow,
if we identify that that policy
violates some rule that we've outlined.
Um, we will pass that rule,
sorry, pass that finding, um, and
the policy that has failed
over to Bedrock.
And instead of just telling the engineer, nah,
your policy's violated something,
go figure out how to fix it, we're actually gonna
give the engineer prescriptive guidance
generated by Bedrock,
um, and one of its many uh
uh managed models,
um,
on how to fix that.
And not only that,
because we're using GitHub actions and our repository
is GitHub, we're gonna
generate an issue that contains that prescriptive
guidance in a nicely formatted way.
So the engineer goes, huh,
great. I, I can see here exactly why it
failed, where I violated my
organizational policies, and what I need to do to go
and fix that.
That's what we're gonna build
I'm gonna hand over to knitting now to
show you to build.
Let's flip to there,
there we go. Mm, OK.
Can everyone hear me well?
OK, awesome.
Thank you, Mitch. So.
We are building automation
in
Uh, in our CICD pipeline,
so that
builder-authored or developer-authored
policies can be validated
against, um, your security
baseline, right?
So, the, the goal, and I'm reiterating
the goal here and we'll revisit the goal
again when we go uh towards the end of this talk.
The goal is to enable
developer agility
or builder agility.
Uh, at the same time by allowing
developers or builders to write their own policies
and roles, but at the same time enforce
security team
provided guardrails in the CICD pipeline
itself, right? So this is kind of the overall
goal. So let's get started now this slide,
um, it talks about, it gives an
overall,
uh, view of steps that we are going to
follow in the next 15 minutes or
so, I will.
Uh, I'll show you the whole build
or the infrastructure setup, and then Mitch
will come back and go over the actions
code, uh, step by step, right?
So, let's get with it. So, 1st 8
steps here,
um, will be, we'll be performing using
the persona of a security engineer. Mitch talked
about that.
Uh, this will set the pipeline, set the automation,
you know, set the plumbing and bells and whistles,
uh, to, to make it happen.
Then we'll come back
as a developer or as a builder, we'll check
in a policy, and then that will
essentially test out uh what
we have built in the 1st 8
steps of this, of this talk, right? So, OK, let's
get started.
Uh, I will first
show, this is the repository we are going
to use.
I have cloned this repository
locally.
I will be using Quiro today,
um,
and we'll also be using Quiro,
uh, command line interface, which is a very nifty
tool. Uh, it comes with, uh, a
lot of bells and whistles, as I said,
and we'll be using this to, to,
over the, over the court talk.
OK. So first,
Let us set up authentication
between GitHub and AWS,
right? So,
um,
uh, here,
first I'll create, we have created
an identity provider in
our AWS account.
Pay attention to a couple of
kind of configuration items here. One is
the provider points to the OIDC
endpoint
of GitHub.
Uh, we'll come to that quickly.
And then also the audience is STS.
Amazon AWS.com, right? So you might ask,
OK, why are we going over this,
uh, authentication from GitHub to AWS,
right? We are, we are here to, here to, uh,
do a court talk, right?
Uh, it just, it will be
important because this is kind of an important pillar.
The reason we are doing this is we don't want to vend
out, uh, long-term credentials
or we don't want to store our
access keys into GitHub, right?
So for that, GitHub needs to get
temporary credentials from AWS in order
if GitHub has to make a call to Access Analyzer,
as Mitch was saying, it needs to get temporary
credentials. So the way this works
is,
uh, when, and we'll go over that
process uh on in this slide.
When the GitHub actions workflow
runner is at a step
where it needs to make a call to
AWS services,
it first reaches out
to the GitHub OIDC endpoint.
The GitHub OIDC endpoint returns a
signed
Java web token or a or
a JWT or a JT token.
Now, among other things, this token.
Contains uh attributes also known
as claims, right? So, for example, one of the
claims in this token can be what is the
repository name,
uh, what is the subject
uh or the audience. These are the claims in this
token. Once the actions
workflow runner gets this token,
it then makes an assumed role with
web identity call
to AWS STS service.
Now, AWS STS service will
then use
the identity provider setup
that we just created.
To, because the,
uh, is there a question? Yeah, sorry,
yeah, sorry, the identity provider, do you
have to set up one per account
that you want to do this in or can you set it up
at the like.
Manage an account and use it across
your. Um, in this
case, because you are, uh, going to
make a call to that account, ST account, you
will have to set it up in the account level.
Um, the way the, the identity provider that
you set at the org level is for
org level actions, right?
Uh, so for example, if you have to use IDC
and then you want to use that identity provider
to sync up users into the, uh, into your IDC
and all that, right? Uh, this is a very
specific OIDC identity provider,
uh, that you will set up at this account level.
Yeah, thanks.
Uh, we have OIDC for other repositories,
tools like bucket.
Uh,
so, in this case, the OIDC endpoint is
what matters, right? So as long as you have
access to the OIDC endpoint, you can set it
up. The reason why we need that OIDC endpoint
is for authentication,
AWS will reach out to the OIDC endpoint,
get the public key, and then use that
public key to validate the signature of the token
that is presented to uh AWS
account. So, as long as
uh any of these OIDC providers have
an endpoint, which can, which have a
key endpoint or which have a token endpoint, then we
can use that.
Makes sense, yeah.
Yeah, great questions. OK.
So, uh,
STS will then
use the connection or the IDP that we
have created to validate the signature
on the token.
That essentially completes the authentication
process, right? Now we come to the authorization
part. Uh,
Sorry, let me take a step back.
STS will vary the token and then
return temporary credentials to
GitHub actions workflow, which are
scoped to a role. And by the way, the role
is also passed in the AU role with Ravanity
call, right?
Now, let's quickly look at the configuration
of this role that we have set up
in our AWS account.
Um, so,
in the, the role that is
role scope credentials that that particular
role has got two different policies. One is
the trust policy, and then one is a
permissions policy. The trust policy
defines what principals are
allowed to make an assume roll call to the role, and
the permissions policy defines what
permissions are given
to the temporary credentials that are
returned back as roll scope credentials,
right? So in our case,
Uh, the role trust policy, we are narrowing
it down to our repository in
GitHub. So these two conditions that we have
created here, one is that, uh, this
subject condition and the audience condition.
The subject condition,
uh, narrows the principles
that can
make an assumed roll call to this role
just to requests originating from
our GitHub repository. So this
clamps it down a little bit.
And then
STS. Amazon AWS.com, that is the
audience that is also one of the attributes
in the job token.
And that is that defines who
this job token or what this job token is intended
for and in this case it's STS, right? So
this is a pretty, uh, you know, least privileged
uh policy that we have in the trust
relationship.
The permissions relationship or the permissions policy
that we have in the role,
um, notice that we have permissions
to 3 different AWS services.
One is we have permissions to Bedrock. We'll
come to that.
Uh, we have permissions to S3 buckets.
We'll also see that in a minute why we need that.
And of course we have permissions for Access
Analyzer because we are going to make calls
to Access Analyzer APIs from our GitHub
actions workflow.
OK, so we'll come back to our PowerPoint
to just get ourselves situated.
Um, at this point, we have seen configuration
for,
uh, set up for the 1st 3 steps.
And so we created the IDC, uh,
OIDC provider, we created the permissions policy,
we created the role, uh, within AWS.
Next, we will
make a configuration setup in
GitHub. So,
uh, GitHub Actions workflow
runner at runtime
needs access to some configuration parameters. We
don't want to store those configuration parameters
or hardcode them in the Actions workflow runner.
So we do that at a place
called Secrets. In GitHub, in our case,
we have stored 3 different secrets
in the repository. One is the AWS Region.
Uh, pretty self-explanatory.
One is the OIDCIM role, which needs,
which the GitHub actions workflow runner
needs to make the assume roll call,
and then the S3 bucket. And we'll
straight away come to why we need the S3 bucket here.
OK, so,
let's talk a little bit about, uh,
reference policies. Now,
access analyzer reference policies are
a mechanism by which,
um,
You can express
your control
or the intent for control, right?
So what that means is that Mitch talked about the
check no new access API in Access Analyzer.
The way that API works is that you pass
in the check no new access flag. Uh, it's a
CFN policy validator wrapper to that.
You also pass in two different policies
to that API.
One of the policies is what is called the candidate
policy. In our case, the candidate
policy is going to be the policy that
the developer or the builder checks into
our repository,
and the next attribute or second attribute
we pass is the reference policy.
The way it works is if the
candidate policy is not
a subset of the reference policy,
then that API returns a finding,
a check no new access finding, meaning it says, oh,
you know, the candidate policy has new access,
then what is defined in the reference policy.
Uh, so this is a pretty
powerful kind of, uh, API that we can
use at runtime for a lot of automation
that we can think about, right?
Now, in our case, as I said, we are
going to, uh, you know, pass the,
uh, builder policy as a candidate policy.
The security engineering team has already
written these reference policies into the repository,
and we'll see where, how that is set up.
Now, before I go, before we
go and look at our reference policy, I wanted to
show a very handy kind of
repository. It's a, it's a, our
colleagues at uh AWS have built
a repository. Of reference policies.
Now this is
amazing. There are a bunch of identity,
uh, resource reference policies here.
All the use cases are here in case you are,
uh, thinking of building this kind of an automation,
uh, strongly recommend, uh, highly suggested
to visit this and then get all these policies
from here.
Um, we will, we will show
a link to this, um, to this repository
at the end of the talk.
We'll show a, uh, you know, a barcode for that.
But in fact,
the reference policy that we are looking in our uh
court talk today is also directly picked up from this repository.
There are a lot of use cases also here. So,
a very nice uh uh resource to
visit. Uh, so let's come to our
reference policy.
Now, the mental model
or the way you can think about reference policies
is, um,
similar to service control policies. So, how,
uh, show of hands, uh, how many of us
are using service control policies?
Yeah, yeah, I'm really glad.
Uh, yeah, this is really good.
This is more than what we usually see.
So the service control policies
and reference policies, the way we start off
by giving
all access,
and then we add another statement in the policy
which defines
what access we want to control.
So in this case, in our use case,
we are saying that in our reference policy
or the reference policy that the security engineer will
check in. Um, we are saying
that if
for all actions other than the
assumed role action, right? So, which is the not
action here,
allow everything.
So, we are not concerned about anything
other than the assumed role action.
But if the action is SDS
assumed role,
Then only allow principals from
these two accounts
um in the policy, which is,
in this case, is going to be the candidate policy.
Now, what,
what would be kind of a real-life use
case where
Uh, one would want to have
this kind of a reference policy,
uh, in the CICD pipeline automation, right? So,
we, Mitch and I, we talk to a lot of customers.
We see customers, uh, multi-account
strategy
being, uh, around,
uh, business units, right? So,
most of the time there will be, I'm just making
this up, sales business unit or marketing business
unit, and each of these will be allocated 456
different accounts.
The development teams that are building
applications for these business units.
If they are given
access or if they are given permissions to write
their own rules and policies,
then there's no reason for any policy
that is checked into a particular business unit
to have assumed role
allowed
from outside the 3 or 4 accounts
or 5 or 6 accounts that are allocated to the business
unit, right? So this is a pretty,
you know, common use case that we see
uh when we talk to our customers. So
in this case,
the security engineer is saying, OK, any
policy that is checked into this repository.
If it has an assumed role action,
then the principal has to be one of these two accounts,
right? So,
let's now look at
how or where this policy is stored. So,
in,
in our case,
um, in our automation, we
are the security engineering team is storing, they're
not adding this policy to the same repository. They are
storing this policy into an S3 bucket,
uh, which is what we have done here.
Uh, and at runtime, so this is now,
that is the reason why you can make, uh,
you know, sense of the two things that we added earlier,
two configuration items. One is
we added the S3 permissions in our role
permissions policy, and we also added
S3 bucket into the configuration
for our, uh, GitHub secrets,
right? For which should be accessible to the GitHub workflow runner.
Um, now, let's come to
the actual
workflow code that puts everything together.
Now, Uh, Mitch will go
over this code, as I said,
but one kind of configuration item
here is that
the way, uh,
and I, I think for, for those who are not dealing
with, uh, GitHub actions workflows,
the way this works is
any YAML file that you check in
into a GitHub slash workflows
directory into, in your repository
is uh interpreted as a workflow
or as an actions workflow by GitHub,
and then it is, uh, you know, executed
in a runner.
Uh, as and when the triggers that are defined in the
workflow are happening, right? So in our case,
we have, uh, we have checked in this
workflow into a .gitHub slash
workflows directory, uh, as, as is seen
here. So
now let us go back and get situated
into our steps, right? OK.
So we.
Finished the authentication set up
in the 1st 3 steps. Uh, we did
the GitHub secrets. We created the reference policy.
We talked about reference policies.
We uploaded the policy
onto S3. We created the workflow directory,
and we created the actions workflow YAML file.
Uh, uh, I would suggest
to just be patient, not to go through the YAL file.
I will not go through it right now. Mitch is going to
do that in a minute.
Now, let's come back and as a, as a
developer, uh, we will test this
out. So I'm, I'm a developer,
um,
my code is giving me,
um, you know,
access denied errors, right? What else is new?
So, I will, uh, I will
show first the way, uh, OK,
so this is, this is the,
uh, uh cloud formation template
that I'm checking in
and I'm getting access denied errors. I have a deadline.
What I will do is I will uh change
the principle and make it a principal
star here, right?
I have saved this. Now,
the classic troubleshooting step.
Exactly.
Uh.
So, uh, I will, uh, I'm
hoping that my CSCD pipe, I will no longer get any
access denied errors.
Uh, my CSCD pipeline should succeed in this
case, but if I were, if I am a
security engineer, this is a classic no
no. I am hoping that the controls
that I have put in, in the repository, uh,
are going to, uh, not allow this to happen,
right? So let me, uh,
check in this code.
Can everyone see? Yeah.
OK, looks all right.
I am doing a Git commit.
And then I'll do a get push. Did that joke
land? My daughter was telling me it will not land at
all. She's like, OK,
Dad, you know, this is too lame. Why are you doing this?
Sorry. Thank
you. OK, so I'm doing a get
push. Um, OK, now,
Uh, OK.
So,
uh, as a, as a, as a developer, I'm
like, OK, now what else is going to give me
an access denied? I'm, I have done, uh, you
know, principal Star, right?
So I should not get the access deny at all. My
CICD pipeline should succeed.
Let us look at the way this, uh,
this pipeline is now getting executed,
um. Yeah, we are going
to our repository
and we go to actions.
Because I used this already yesterday, so I'm using a
2 here. Again, a classic developer
thing. So,
uh, what happens, what is happening in
these steps is GitHub
then based on the triggers has
loaded our YAML file
and the steps and is executing the steps
in our YAML file.
Now, all this, I don't have access. I'm
not, I, I, I, as a, as a builder, I'm
not looking at all these things, right?
Um, I will go back and I will show you what happens.
In my case,
uh, as a, as a builder persona.
I will
take a look at this and see
if my CRCD pipeline succeeded, my code got
deployed or not.
At this point, you will see that
we already have blocking findings,
and we already,
the pipeline did fail. So if I go back
to actions here.
Uh, my pipeline failed. I got an
email message saying an issue has been created.
Now, think about this. The reason I
talked to you, this is the issue that got created,
uh, just now.
Now, the reason I said or
we reiterated the goal earlier
is
developer agility was our kind of,
kind of, uh, goal, right?
Now, prior to.
Us being able to make a call to Bedrock
in order to give us prescriptive guidance
as a as a builder, as a developer, what
I just had to shift my troubleshooting
from troubleshooting access denied error messages to
troubleshooting why the CICD pipeline failed, right?
Now, in this case, if you
see the issue that is created,
it tells me exactly what statement
I checked in.
It then tells me what is the reference policy
that the security engineering team has put in here,
has put in the repository. It tells me
why this is a security risk, what is the intent
of this kind of failure, and it also
gives me the exact fix that I will
have to do in order to fix this problem,
right? So, this is kind of
uh really, you know, in our mind, a game
changer. Uh, we are really excited
about the possibilities that we
have here when we can make this call.
So, for, for example, what we're talking about
is, is it possible for us to
maybe
not even have, uh,
the, the builder write the
policy, um, you know, uh, some
of us did,
uh, talk about the co-pilot launch yesterday, right,
uh, the co-pilot release. So why
not have co-pilot craft a
policy and then,
uh, the pilot, sorry.
Uh, autopilot. Oh my God, that's a
Freudian slip.
So autopilot, uh, uh, craft
the policy,
then, uh,
call, uh, GitHub,
uh, this, uh, you know, uh, actions workflow,
call Access Analyzer,
check that the crafted policy is
also,
um, you know, as per the boundaries.
Find here in the guard rail and then go forward,
right? So we're really looking forward if we can do something like that.
We at this point we are not sure we can, we can do that. But
so, uh, what I am saying here is
just a year back or a couple of years
ago, um,
this was not really a developer agility
kind of enabling, uh, mechanism, but now
it is, it has taken a different kind of, uh, flavor.
So I, as a, I, I have, I'm
here, I got,
um, the I got the actual,
uh, prescriptive guidance as to why this
CICD pipeline failed.
I will go back and make a change to my policy,
uh, saying, OK, I will only allow
um
the accounts that are allowed
for me, right?
I hope I typed the right number of ones.
Uh, in this case,
Again, I will check in this code.
And I will just make it a 2. Only
privilege gets allowed.
Uh, Get push.
So now,
I know for sure, or I'm fairly
certain as a, as a builder also that
because I, I have
um uh sort of adhere
to what has been
uh in the guardrails in the CSCD
pipeline,
this, uh, you know, actions workflow should
succeed now.
I guess maybe, um, I
hand it over to Mitch and then once Mitch is done, we'll come
back and see if the workflow succeeded.
Cool, do you wanna bring the um the work
flow up on your, in your.
Cool, there we go, excellent.
That's it. So
the first thing I'll notice is that we're using Kro
because Kro's cool.
Um,
the, in case you hadn't heard of the autopilot,
uh, thing that, that Nitin was mentioning as
well, so we launched this last week, um,
pre-reinvent, um, and it's an MCP
server
for, uh, Quiro or any other
MCP client that's out there,
which, uh, it, it's called IAM
Policy Autopilot is the full name for it,
but it essentially will look at,
uh, the application code that you
have written.
Um,
in, and it will,
uh, generate an IEM policy
based on the different API actions
that you're calling.
If you've, if you've imported one of the SDKs
and you're calling S3 to list buckets,
and that's the only thing that your piece of
application code is doing,
then, um,
the IM policy autopilot
will create that,
just that policy for you.
Um, least privileged, it has
a lot of AWS knowledge and context, so
it will, um, make sure that the policy syntax
is correct and accurate.
Um, it will aim to do least privilege where possible
as well,
uh, and then you can commit that into
the, um, into the, the repo,
um, in the same way that we've just done with, with
that policy a minute ago.
So that's what that is worth while having a look, it's pretty
cool. Um, so let's go through this
workflow. If you've used GitHub actions
before, which most of you seem to have done, you'll
be pretty familiar with, with what we've got here. The
first few sections are fairly self-explanatory.
We're only triggering when, um, we
are pushing changes to a certain branch,
uh, anything, uh, below the, the kind of features
slash branch.
We are only
triggering it when there are changes to,
um, YAML files in
a particular folder within the repost.
This is where we're changing a roll trust policy.
Um, we are only triggering
when, uh, it's, uh,
a pull request as well. Um, so
those are the kind of conditions for triggering.
Then we've got the permissions. This is where we're defining
what the runners can do, so whether it's hosted
or, or self-managed.
Um, ID token is essentially
the uh the permission it will need,
uh, the runner will need in order to complete
the, um, OIDC handshake to get
the, the, the temporary credentials from AWS.
Um, the content,
um, commission is
set to right, which means that the
reader, the, the.
Runner will be able to read and write content from
the repository, and then the issues
permission um is set to write as well
because we want the runner to be able to create
issues when it identifies these blocking
findings. Now we get to the interesting part where
things are a little bit different from maybe your, your traditional
run and flow.
So we've got a job, uh, our overarching job is
called CFNIM policy validation.
Uh, the runner you'll see is just a fairly
generic Ubuntu latest runner at the minute,
one of the ones that we can get from, from GitHub's,
uh, Git, uh, actions environment fairly easily.
This is hosted or managed, um,
on their environment. You can do a, uh,
a self-hosted
version of this as well in your own environments.
Why would you want to do that? Well, maybe
your build process relies on some internal
private repository for, uh, dependencies.
Maybe you've got an artifactory deployment or
you need to talk to a database to register your
application with some configuration management codes, something
like that. So there are a few different reasons why you would
approach that.
Um, obviously if it's in GitHub's own
environments uh as a managed runner, then you wouldn't
be able to access those private resources.
Um, but we've got hosted for now.
Then we've installed the fairly standard
and well used um
action for checking out code, that's
fairly straightforward.
Now we're installing an open source
tool called CFN Policy Validators.
This is a Python tool that was created by
some of our colleagues at AWS
that will essentially.
grok a cloud formation template,
extract the IAM related
resources out of it, and then pass
them to the IAM
Access Analyzer APIs
to do the validation and
any of the custom policy check
capabilities that are brought up on the screen there.
Then we're configuring the credentials, which is where our
previous um
ID privilege comes into play.
Fairly straightforward with the exception of
the fact there that we are using the secrets
that we defined or that Nitin defined earlier on
to extract some of the environment specific
information that we need, including the role name.
Then we're fetching the resource policy
or the reference policy should I say, from S3.
So Knitin showed you that was already an S3
at the minute, um,
you know, you might have a,
a pipeline or a mechanism to, to
govern that process of creating those
and pushing them into S3.
I, I, I have a customer that uses Dynamo
DB to store these things, um, and
they have, based on the, the,
where, which team is doing the pull request or
or is pushing the code in, they pull down different
reference policies and check the,
the policies that the team is trying to create
based on.
The the the the persona or the
team that's coming in, so there's a few ways of doing that, but
essentially what you want to do is make sure that these reference policies
are centralized
so that you can access them as part of these
workflows. You don't want them to exist
within the context of the repo because that kind of
defeats the object of having these centralized
reference policies.
Um,
Now we're passing the cloud formation template, so
we're using the CFN policy validator
tool, uh, it has an uh an argument
uh or a parameter called PAS.
What we're doing there is we're, we're essentially doing
really what that tool does by default, which
is scrape the cloud formation
template, extract any resources
that are related to IAM users' roles,
um, groups, um, and policies,
trust policies as well,
uh, and drop them into a file, and we're
gonna come back and use that file a little bit later on.
Um,
then we're running the AWS Access
Analyzer check no new access
check. So this is where we're, we're triggering,
um, the access analyzer capabilities.
Now, what you'll notice here is where it
says users, we're using, uh,
an, a, a native action called cloud
formation AWS IAM policy validator,
which essentially is the same as the Python
thing that we installed a little bit earlier on.
And you might be going, well that doesn't seem very efficient, there's
a bit of duplication there, why are you doing
that? The reason we're doing it at the minute
is that the uh the native
action doesn't include the pass functionality.
Um, it, so in order for us to
do the thing that we're doing with Bedrock, and you'll
see in a minute more about that,
we need that pass functionality to
take all the resources out,
the, the IM resources out. So
if you didn't need to do the thing with Bedrock that we're gonna
show you in a bit, you could just use that native
action which is available in the, the, the
actions marketplace, um, you can install
it and use it that way.
Configuration is all fairly straightforward you can see
there, uh we've got the template path so
that is the the the template that we're
analyzing in this scenario,
then we've got the uh reference policy,
so this is the.
The, the gold standard, nothing, no
policy that gets created should have permissions
beyond the, the scope of that one.
we're defining what type of resource, sorry,
what type of policy this is. So this is a resource
policy because we're looking at,
um, it's uh it's a role, we're analyzing
a role trust policy.
Um, you may need to add a couple of different runs
of that, that particular action there or
that step in the flow if you wanted
to analyze for identity related
policies. In fact, you wouldn't, you may,
you would need to do it. It's not, you would, if you, yeah, we
don't unfortunately at the minute you can't just have
like no ref, uh,
no policy type.
Um,
sorry, just scroll back up there for me for a second,
and then we're choosing the region because you need
to tell, um, the API,
the, the, the tool which region it needs
to use to, to call the access analyzer APIs.
Uh, then we're running,
um,
uh, now some kind of arbitrary
code here just to try and get,
uh, the results of the analyzer
out of, uh, of, of
the check. So we've got the results back now, so
we're passing that and we're trying to determine how many
blocking findings there are.
Now we don't want to run
the bedrock part of this demo
if there are no blocking findings, we
only wanna do it if there's blocking findings. So we're
looking for blocking findings, we're analyzing that,
um, we go down there and what we're starting
to do then is we're looking, if you can see down there,
we're taking the, the outputs of some of these
steps and we're putting them into GitHub outputs so
that we can access them a little bit uh later
on down the process.
We are also now,
so if you've ever used custom policy checks
before, um, either
directly using um the SDKs
or using one of the CLI tools,
you will
notice that the results and response you get back
isn't particularly helpful,
other than saying
you've got a blocking finding.
And it was this policy that
was the problem,
and it was this statement index number
where you've got the issue. If you've got a big
policy that has lots of different statements
within it, um,
and it, and you know, you're and you're an engineer, a software
engineer for example, and, and grocking IEM
policies isn't something you enjoy doing.
Then it can be quite challenging to go through
that and kind of go to like 0123,
that statement there like
so what we're trying to do is we're trying to take
that past policy that we, we
passed earlier on in in the step above,
um, and we're taking the results from Access
Analyzer and it's gonna say
this policy name.
This statement index ID.
So we're doing the heavy lifting as part of this
process to get the exact statement out
of the policy that has the issue.
Quick point,
I've been talking about cloud formation a lot.
Um, the CFN policy validator
is specifically for cloud formation.
There is a TFN policy validator.
Can anyone guess what that's for?
There you go, see?
So that's exactly. So you can do that as well, if
you, if you were using terraform.
Um, where are we down here now? OK,
so then we, uh, we've got our problematic
statements, uh, in a, in a text file. Um,
we are now, uh,
writing the information into GitHub output so we can
access it down in the next step of our workflow.
So now we're kicking off the generate AI,
um, powered workflow, which is only
happening if, um, if we have a
blocking statement.
So what we're doing is we're taking,
um,
I'll take a step back here and.
I say we're building a dynamic
prompt as part of the next step of what you're
about to see here.
So we've got an I, we, we've we've
created this prompt, we know what we want Bedrock
to provide us, we've got some prescriptive guidance
so we can give it back to the developer.
So the next section you can see here is,
um, we're essentially.
Adding the variables that we've created,
which are populated based on the,
the output from the different stages above,
uh, we're putting them into variables and
we're constructing now this, this custom
prompt, this dynamic prompt,
and we're gonna start to inject,
uh, into some placeholders there which you can see
the reference policy,
the validation result, and the problematic
statements.
So, all of that now has been bundled
together into a into a prompt.
That gets dynamically generated based
on the specific results of that
particular push.
Um, the things that we want to be consistent
are with how we want the prescriptive guidance
to come back, what we want the model to do
for us, so we've kept that in there,
but we're just adding the dynamic bits in there as well,
and we're giving it some very clear instructions there on
what we kind of want it to do as well, how to
update the cloud formation template,
check where it aligns with the reference policy,
so we've been very prescriptive in for the most
part. Then we are taking
that prompt that we've just built now that's been populated
with all this really good information, we're writing
it out into a JSON file,
and then we are invoking the Bedrock
API
with the JSON file with the prompt in it.
And it's, it's doing its thing.
And then as we scroll down a little bit more, in fact
there's the invocation part there, and if we
scroll down a little bit more, we're gonna
get back then a response
from um from Bedrock hopefully
which comes with some useful
information that we can pass on to the developer.
So then we are now going
to generate the GitHub issue, we're
going to
populate that issue with all of that
information, we're gonna make it look nice, so it looks kind of
nice and friendly as well for the, for the developer.
Um, with all the kind of clarity around
what they need to do next and, and all the structure that
you saw in the example earlier on,
and. That's it.
That's how that
that that the mechanism works.
So let's go back now and see if er
Nitin's
push um with the working
trust policy er looks as we
expect it to look.
Which is no issue generated because
he was using one of the trusted accounts.
Yeah. Uh,
yeah, so in this case, you will see that
the next, uh, code push that we did
with the correct policy, uh, CSCD pipeline
succeeded. One thing here is that Mitch
did mention
that if the bedrock or if the
blocking findings are there, only then we call
the bedrock analysis. In this case, you will
see that there is no blocking findings, so that's why we
don't call the bedrock analysis at all, in this case.
So one of the interesting things about this as well that's worth
keeping in mind is at the minute we're building
these checks in on the left hand
side of the,
the policy development life cycle, software
development life cycle, wherever you want to, whatever term you want
to use. Um
There are going to be things
that that are already deployed in your environment
that that you don't want to happen in, in
uh in your AWS accounts, and you can use the
existing analyzers to some degree to to detect
some of those things, um, especially if it's
permissions that you don't want people to use or
they shouldn't be using or they're never using anyway, um,
Dynamo DB delete table, S3 bucket,
delete, um,
S3 delete bucket.
Any of the other things that you might not want them to use
and custom, you know, sensitive resources
that might have been created that you never think
anyone should be able to access other than maybe
the security team or the legal team, that
kind of thing. So as you,
so as, as you've got these the the
the analyzers running in your accounts
detecting the existing policies and the
things that perhaps you want to apply as
best practice, you can feed that
back out into your reference policies
or into a list of sensitive
actions and sensitive API calls.
Which then can be scanned for or checked
for using this mechanism the next
time an engineer checks in the
policy or the cloud formation template that they're checking
in, and this is kind of the cycle
that will continue to flow then this this um,
This cycle where you, you identify a,
a bad practice,
you feed it back into the reference policy, it gets checked
the next time someone builds something, great, and
you'll find you over time you're just refining this
and making sure that every new policy
that gets created into your environment
only contains the things that you, your
organization is, is happy for it to contain, nothing
more, nothing less.
So that's how that will work, and how we envisage
that would work as well. So I think that's pretty cool.
We think it's pretty cool.
So Promised QR codes.
Um,
These are massive QR codes, and
I'll tell you why they're massive QR codes. It's
because,
uh, in a session I ran previously, not,
not at this conference, at another event, I think
I jammed about 5 or 6 QR codes
onto one screen.
And people's phones just could not focus
on those QR codes. It was quite just I was
trying to do this and this and this, so we've gone, right, you
know what, we'll go one massive QR code
per piece of content
per slide. So we've got 3 huge
QR codes for you.
If anyone's phone isn't able to
zero in on that,
might be time to upgrade.
OK, so this workshop content will walk you
through kind of what we've built today, and I say
kind of
because it doesn't include the bedrock
part
yet.
And the only reason it doesn't include the bedrock part
yet is that we just haven't got round to
merging that new update into this.
We will do.
Um, someone asked me yesterday when we ran this
session, when?
And I said because you asked so nicely and
because I've got a 15 hour flight back to Australia,
I'll do it on that 15 hour flight.
So maybe the next time you check that that that
repo for the workshop content, it will be done.
Blog post, this is a blog post, uh,
let me do the, yeah, let me do the QR codes and then we'll we'll
come back to you. Sorry.
Um, another massive QR code, this is a blog
post that kind of talks about what we've just talked about
today as well, um, the process, why it's
useful, how to set it up and configure it, and
also links back to the workshop as well. So if
you didn't manage to get the last massive QR
code, get this one, cos you'll find your way back
to that workshop repository
anyway. OK,
I can't see no more cameras.
And then the last bit, policy samples.
OK, um, this is the repo
that K Nitin brought up earlier on. If you
plan to build your own reference policies, if
you want to do something like that we've shown you here
today with, with GitHub actions or even,
you know, whatever
CICD tooling you're using.
Uh, or if you just want to use, uh, access
analyzers, custom policy checks through the command
line tool, um, you can do it.
Uh, but those reference policies are a really good place to
start. We've got examples of reference policies
that are good for resource policies and
good for identity-based policies as well.
So have a look at those.
And then the last.
Slide, oops, there's it, I'm gonna skip that one,
that's not important.
Is this slide
with our names and our contact details,
of which we're very happy for you to reach out to
us and
email us, ask us questions, connect with us on
LinkedIn, whatever you want to do.
Um, because we love talking to customers about
this kind of thing.
And one really important item
at the bottom there in the left hand corner is
please complete the session survey in the mobile
application. And the reason that's important is because
we wanna know if you enjoyed this session, if
you got something out of it, if you learned something, and
if not, what could we do better next time to make sure
that when we come back and do something like this
again, it meets your expectations.
So please, if you have some time.
Uh, even before you leave today, um, please
fill out the session survey. It is greatly
appreciated. Um,
so that is the end of what we wanted to share
today. Enjoy. Thank you very much
for coming, really appreciate it. Thank you.